all right guys listen it's been one hell
of a year and on this show guess what
we're gonna do we're gonna look back at
all the stuff that you remember and all
the moments that you wish you could
forget that's right let's kick it off
with checking my damn headlight shaking
my damn headlines Keenan I'm so excited
about this one let's go and what may
have been legit or just a senior moment
President Joe Biden said that the
pandemic is over wait real question is
it over that's what I want is it over
you know I can't honestly it don't even
matter because I'm pretty sure covet is
going to haunt us forever it's like our
old jokes on Twitter or or Madonna on
Tick Tock oh goodness
take a look at this [ __ ] but that's her
now watch this that's Madonna there
Madonna back up back the [ __ ] up Madonna
good no what you doing what is she doing
oh all right thank you okay thank you
very much what just happened I don't
understand what that was well nobody
does to be honest with you if I can get
that part of my life back I'll do
anything to happen I mean what just
happened man yeah but I mean she looks
great yep come on now yeah right yes we
we meet right love lover nobody has
explained to her the algorithm of how
Tick Tock works yeah she thinks this
yeah yeah based on closeness I don't
know what that was yes it's not all
right well when the government announced
that masks were no longer required on
flights Americans on both sides of the
airplane aren't celebrated we lost our
mask in Southwest Airlines when they
lost their dead Minds have you seen this
hello Southwest airlines passengers in
each of your seats we have provided a
ukulele for this flight from California
to Hawaii everybody gets a free ukulele
and free lessons
I'm tired of all these ukuleles on this
[ __ ] ukulele play
Hey I wouldn't want I would have smashed
somebody in the back of the head for not
stopping playing you know what they
shouldn't let you get a ukulele unless
you can spell it let's spell it right
now
just go ahead ukulele so that's uh UK
LL there's a cut up you cut up I'll be
honest with you then don't give me one
yeah don't give me one I don't need it
okay I have no [ __ ] idea how to spell
it all right I can't even spell
Southwest if you want to be honest with
you
is September Queen Elizabeth passed away
Prince Harry well he rushed back to pay
his final respects and Meghan Markle
rushed back to get no respect yeah
unfortunately they arrived a little too
late but they did see footage of the
queen moments before she passed let's
take a look
by the way
okay that old lady to get up there
oh she'd have been through two pandemics
and one Titanic
all right the line to pay the last
respects to the late Queen had people
waiting for up to 27 hours that's right
people you heard me 27 hours even
celebrities had to wait David Beckham
they had David Beckham in line look at
this right uh here it comes right there
he is right there right there with the
red on you saw that Adam in line he's
David Becker I would have bought a fast
pass you can't get a fast pass what
about a fast pass you can't just to get
up to the front Keenan you can't no
that's the line of people participating
in the buyback program for Yeezys
gotta buy them back turn them in turn
them in
when Russia invaded Ukraine the world
rallied around president zielinski the
U.S sent more than 40 billion in
military aid but Sean Penn well he gave
him something even more valuable
[Music]
silly thing I I know but if I use it
here we melt it down and make a weapon
yes use this
as a champion I can't use this this is
not going to do enough when you win
bring it back to Malibu after you get
your Victory I want you to I want you to
crawl out of whatever Rubble or
whatever's there yeah and you bring this
up you bring it back you bring it back
would you ever give your Oscar for
Jumanji away
[ __ ]
if you don't think I deserve one for
that performance you are just like them
overlooking amazing I was like when I
was reading that I was like oh [ __ ] you
gotta ask her for Jumanji and you you
deserved it so I'm sorry that that was a
joke